MALE SPEAKER:
Well, good morning.
Welcome to Authors at Google
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure to
introduce Andrea Coville, who
is CEO of Brodeur Partners
here in Boston with offices--
nationwide, worldwide?
Excellent.
As CEO--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: As CEO, she has
diversified Brodeur Partners
from a PR firm
specializing in technology
to a multi-disciplinary
communications agency focusing
on full service communications,
digital strategy,
social change, and
business consulting.
Her passions include
social issues
that advance the
wellbeing of children.
Today, she's here to discuss
her recent book, "Relevance:
The Power to Change
Minds and Behavior
and Stay Ahead of
the Competition."
I've read this book.
It is definitely, in my
opinion, a cut above all
the other business books.
It has a lot to say on topics
that are much more, pardon
the phrase, relevant
than one might think.
She points out that
organizations spend billions
of dollars annually
in an attempt
to win customers, move products,
and enhance their brand image.
However, many of
these efforts are
missing an essential
element-- relevance.
Miss Coville draws on original
research and two decades
of experience to
offer organizations
a road-tested plan for creating
highly relevant messages
to shift attitudes and, most
importantly, consumer behavior.
Please join me in
welcoming Andrea Brodeur.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREA COVILLE: Thank you
so much for spending then
the next hour or so with me.
I'd love to just to ask you a
little bit about yourselves.
Anybody here from marketing?
Product development?
Maybe you could tell me.
Could you tell me
some of what you do?
AUDIENCE: I'm just an
engineering intern.
And I was excited
to hear your talk.
ANDREA COVILLE: Neat.
How about yourself?
AUDIENCE: I'm in SRE, so
it's also in engineering,
although I've done
politics and music.
ANDREA COVILLE: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: I'm an engineer.
AUDIENCE: I'm an engineer
working with partners,
supporting our partners
in the travel business.
ANDREA COVILLE:
Really interesting.
I know that you are in
the literary business.
AUDIENCE: Oh, but before
that, I worked here
and did systems development.
ANDREA COVILLE: Oh, cool.
How about yourself?
AUDIENCE: I'm in the global
sales organization here.
So it's very topical for
us to talk about relevance
with our clients getting
lots of different messages
and lots of different messages
from us, since we do so much.
AUDIENCE: I'm also
in global sales
and working with
companies often times
to help create a brand
using [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREA COVILLE: Great.
Molly?
AUDIENCE: I'm an
intern at [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I'm an an
engineering intern
who's just really interested
in what you have to say.
ANDREA COVILLE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Engineer in travel.
ANDREA COVILLE: Great.
Well, it is such a pleasure
to meet all of you.
My name is Andy.
Thank you for the very
nice introduction.
And as my background has--
I started out as a writer,
got really interested by
the importance of words,
and then moved into marketing
and actually public relations,
which led me into the
world of communications.
And I think about six years ago
I had this fundamental decision
that I wanted to
make, which was how
to create more meaning in an
industry that, at times, I felt
could be a tad superficial.
And as you all are in
the world of engineering
and the importance of
data and analytics,
in my business
and communications
is that business started
shifting to really emphasizing
the importance of that.
I found out that--
there's someone's phone.
Probably just
knock it off, yeah.
I found that there was less
importance being placed--
do you mind just
turning that off, Molly?
Thank you.
It's my phone, so I
can't blame her for that.
The lack of importance of
putting the insight piece
into the funnel was
something I really
wanted to spend some time on.
And that was the
original hypothesis
when I began working
on the book was--
there was a sort of thinking
that communications could truly
change behavior.
But could we really push that?
Can you think?
Can communications
truly change behavior,
or is it something that can
support behavioral change?
And the word "relevance"
really appealed to me,
because it's an old word.
It's like resilience.
It's an old word that has, I
felt, very powerful meaning.
It's a word that
sometimes advertisers
would use as an index,
essentially, or as a metric.
But to me, relevance as a
word has social and practical
applicability.
And we have choices, right?
We're in a world that
there's a real duality,
I think, in our
environment today.
We have the ability to
select, yet we are saturated.
We have so much
information coming at us.
Why do we choose the things
we choose to engage in?
Why do we choose them,
with so many options?
And beyond that, why do we
actually stay engaged in them?
I always love thinking
about communications
in terms of-- have you ever
had a friend that did something
you truly didn't expect
that friend to do?
Say that friend never went
outside their comfort zone.
They had a life of ritual.
But that friend, all of a
sudden, went to a lecture,
maybe once on Haiti,
and decided-- never
traveled before-- decided
to actually jump on a plane,
go to an orphanage, help
out, help out almost
like in a camping
trip environment,
and came back a completely--
not changed person,
but really a broadened person.
I'm always fascinated
by the insight that
comes from a person, an
idea, a company, a brand that
can open up people emotionally
and get them to connect.
So enter the relevant brand.
And what my research
focused on was
trying to look at some of the
drivers of behavioral change.
Are there are emotional
triggers that we can identify?
And are there maps,
connection points?
And again, my business
is I'm an agency girl.
I've grown up in agencies
and communication.
So I take this from a
communications perspective.
I'm not a behavioral
psychologist.
I'm a communications person.
Our research started by asking
people to self-identify.
And we looked at the
cohorts on the right--
the baby boomers, the Gen
X'ers, the Millennials.
And I don't use those terms,
those cohorts, very often.
But sometimes, in terms
of research like this,
it just makes it easier.
We asked people to
self-identify by age.
And you think about things
like risk taking and ambition.
And that makes sense.
The younger you are, the middle
part you are in your career,
somewhere to 30 to 54, you're
going to be more risky.
Probably is true with your
stock investments as well.
It's interesting to see
how optimism changes.
You tend to-- from
our research, this
is six months old--
tend to be a little more
optimistic before you turn 55.
But the one thing that united
every age group that people
self-identified with, when
chosen, was compassion.
So when you're
thinking about a brand
and you're thinking about
you reaching an individual,
yes, you might be
reaching an engineer.
You might be reaching a doctor.
You might be reaching
a small business owner.
But you are reaching
a human being
that, in most
circumstances, truly
values that compassion is
really relevant to them.
So once you think about the fact
of how people self-identify,
you ask people what is
relevant to them personally.
And this is a-- if
we were on a webinar,
I'd have you vote by
clicking a button.
Which of these
things in our survey
was the most important
of these six?
What do you think came out
as top across all age groups?
AUDIENCE: To make friends?
ANDREA COVILLE: You
nailed it, absolutely.
So the next slide you'll
see important and relevant
to you personally being
understood collectively
is probably the least
important to all of us.
Making a difference starts
getting really important.
Staying healthy, of course.
But personally,
what we care about
is that our friends and
family, in caring for them--
not just caring for them
in a healthcare sense,
but caring for
them emotionally--
is very, very important.
And as you all know, you've seen
the research, the only people
that truly care where
financial security moves up
the list to maybe
the top almost eighth
is the wealthiest people care
about being financially secure.
So if you make
$170,000 or more, you
tend to put the staying
healthy and financially secure
kind of go hand in hand.
But so what we did
was the research,
and I'm going to get into
a little bit more of it.
And I want to show you some
fresh research I've only
showed one other group before.
Most companies and
organizations really
focus on the upper right
hand side, the thinking side.
Which makes a lot of
sense-- it's the rational,
it's the functional
piece of information.
It helps make my needs.
It helps my life,
makes my life easier.
I mean, if you just think about,
as engineers, probably the way
you receive a lot
of information,
it's probably very data driven.
Certainly, with
physicians or surgeons,
you're talking about outcomes
it's very, very specific.
We started looking at
how our data clustered.
And it clustered into
three other areas.
Values, we started
seeing people,
especially if you
look at the way
a human being engages
with a nonprofit,
that's where your
values as a human being
connect to the organization.
And you're going to see
some data we have actually
on your brand, Google, the
values are a very, very
important part of
your external brand.
The social.
I don't mean social media here.
I mean the social networks
that we all bring,
whether it's our bike club, our
book club, who we travel with,
if we have children.
The PTA systems are
our children's friends.
It's the networks we
bring to our environments.
And sensory, this
is the piece that
has been done-- I think-- has
the most incredible potential
in terms of communications.
I mean, I like to use this
example as a category changer,
because what they did-- if
you remember way early on--
and your company is certainly
doing a ton of this--
is they brought a sixth
sensory experience to a very,
I would say, static technology.
And there are tons
and tons of companies
out there, from medical
device companies
to pharmaceutical companies
to consumer companies that
have an incredible
opportunity to explore
the sensory element of engaging
with people emotionally.
And I think there's a
tremendous amount of research.
So some of the metrics
we use in our research
and that correlates to the
quadrants are the following.
So we look for
things like values.
Does it stand for
the same things
human you do as a human being?
If you're associated
with a brand,
how do you feel about yourself?
If you're a runner and you
choose Camel water packs,
and they're a certain size
and they fit when you run,
what does that say about you?
It helps me meet my needs.
Makes my life easier.
There's that functional aspect.
It's not for everyone, but
it's for people like me,
and it inspires me.
And remembering at the
center of all of this
are individuals that care
about their family and friends
and are compassionate.
So there's different
relevance engagement pathways
for different types
of products, we found.
Personal products, it
makes a lot of sense,
and personal products
would be a smartphone
or could even be a RAZR.
But you associate it with the
values that are important.
But most of all, it
really meets your needs.
There's a functional
aspect to it.
High end products like
cars, luxury goods,
or not necessarily luxury cars,
but maybe that's a choice.
Whether you're a Zipcar consumer
or you buy your own car,
part of it is something
about wanting people
to know that you're
associated with it
and it meets your needs.
Professional services,
very, very all
about making your
life easier, thinking
about your relationship
with your accountant.
Again, these are where the
drivers of relevance burst.
But the opportunity
is to look where
the shorter drivers of
relevance are, and is there
an opportunity to explore those?
And certainly with
charitable organizations,
you can see that the
charitable organizations are
very values-based in terms of
their branding communications.
But the data we
just did-- and I'll
show you this in a minute-- that
the functional side, people are
caring more and more about
the return on their donation.
Even if it's $10, they want
to know it goes somewhere.
So here's some
interesting data, when
you start thinking
for our perspective,
about category loyalty.
All problems in the world can
be solved if you bring people
together for food and drink.
I guess that's sort of
the number one thing.
Everybody thinks and is
loyal to food and drink
brands, number one
category loyalty.
News and information
comes second.
And way down at the
end is automobiles.
And with the exception
of consumer electronics,
it's pretty evenly
skewed, brand loyalty
between men and
women of all ages.
Then you look at category
level against age,
against different demographics.
And what's interesting to me
is that news and information
sources from the 18 to
24 cohort and the 65 plus
have a lot in common.
And certainly, I would say the
Gen X'ers, the Gen Y'ers, food
and drink are really key.
But it's interesting to see
the media consumption so
important at both ends
of the age axis here.
If you look at this
across ethnicities
you can see the ranking order
of category loyalty going
from left to right
were food and drink
is the most across
all ethnicities,
going down to automobiles,
which is the least category
loyalty-- although
Caucasians have the highest
loyalty to automobiles,
and African Americans
skew the highest in terms of
news and information sources.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would
you mind explaining
what brand or category loyalty
means exactly here for food
and drink on [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREA COVILLE:
It means that they
have those questions
that I showed you
a couple slides about.
They have answered
those questions,
and they've also indicated
that they will stay.
They care most.
We asked them, out of
all of these categories,
what you care most
about, and what do you
change your preferences
about least?
So you don't switch, like
your favorite restaurants,
your favorite beers.
You stay loyal to them
over a period of time.
So again, here's here a
little bit more about this.
Among the
organizations, if you're
looking at relevance
profiles of organizations,
we asked people again
in our research,
what organizations
most share your values?
And this is where
Google comes up.
Is at the most interesting
and exciting out of people
we put or companies we
put in your category?
Who would you miss
most if you were gone,
and who would you like
to do business with?
So this is six months of data.
And you can see that-- I don't
think it would surprise you--
that Microsoft has a lot
of this from for decades
a sort of embedded brand
relevance in corporations.
Apple, certainly through
its-- in the Steven Jobs era--
really, really created this.
People thought of them
as the most interesting.
But what was so interesting to
us about the Google responses
were that people would
miss you the most.
And I think it's just if
it's people haven't even
experienced any other product
other than just search, if you
ask people, if you took the
ability to do Google search out
of your daily life, what
would your life be like?
You people would say,
I couldn't stand it.
We would completely miss it.
And even if that's
the only entry
point they have into your brand,
the other interesting thing
about this was the values
piece, the values the company
I see my own personal
values in the way
the company behaves and brands.
And that was very, very
strong for Google as well.
So we're looking
at another, we're
looking at now
brand ambassadors.
And those are people
who go out of their way
to create a positive impression
of your brand with others.
These are male and female.
And it's interesting, with
the exception of Intel and HP,
most of the brand
ambassadors skew female.
If you look at
income, you can see
that what I found
interesting here
is some of the best brand
ambassadors actually make
the least amount of money
in terms of brand investors.
So they go out of their way
to communicate their brand
preferences.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you
identify brand ambassadors?
ANDREA COVILLE: Brand--?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, ambassadors.
ANDREA COVILLE: They
commit to word of mouth.
They will commit to a
word of mouth action
on behalf of a brand and
behaviors that show they share
and endorse the brand-- like,
for example, communicating
about the experience on
their social media networks
throughout their communities.
Right.
AUDIENCE: It's the difference
between like a brand and then
liking it so much
that you want to talk
to other people about it.
ANDREA COVILLE: Exactly.
So this looks at
it, and it never
underestimates those group of
people, whether they're younger
or they make the least
amount of money that
are using your product.
They'll be making more
money probably before long.
And they're very, very, very
powerful brand ambassadors
for your brand in the
next 10 to 20 years.
Then we looked at-- this is sort
of interesting-- organization
relevance.
If you look at the
communities people
belong to outside of work,
are they particularly
loyal to any kinds of
civic organizations,
or they have a
religious affiliation,
or they think government
is doing a good job.
And I guess it's pretty
clear that BlackBerry brand
ambassadors feel that
government is doing a good job.
And Microsoft has
a lot of people
that belong to a
civic organization.
It's just interesting
to see where they work
and where they play, or what
they think about outside.
Now, you can apply this
to any market segment.
And I'm going to show you in
a minute some very fresh data
around law firms and banking
institutions and higher
education.
But in retail stores,
when we did this survey
and then we redid it within
a 24-month period of time,
Target has not changed.
And you would have thought that
Target would have been impacted
by the security breaches
in a really negative way.
But I think Target was
so relevant to people
on so many levels, I mean
it's fun to go in there.
It's a sensory experience.
It's easy to find
and grab some food.
You can get good bargains.
It's fun.
They have a lot of goodwill
that has been associated
with that at a retail level I
think that has really carried
over and carried
them through this.
And people aren't willing to
give up that experience, even
for some of the
security breaches.
Our next film cut of
data is looking at,
can you look at
drivers of relevance
and look at increases
in market cap over time?
Does it make a difference?
That's our next [INAUDIBLE].
And it'll be interesting to
look at Target and Walmart
two years now and see if there
are financial analytics that
correspond to
drivers of wellness.
Now, were talking
about Comcast earlier
before the talk started.
And I would say that
telecommunications
is a pretty tough industry
to differentiate in.
If you're head of marketing for
a telecommunications industry,
it's challenging.
But clearly,
Verizon-- whether it's
through some of their
corporate partnerships,
whether it's through
the product line
that they offer, whether it's
through their storefronts,
their retail operations.
They have significantly
more drivers
of relevance than
the competition.
Beverage companies,
another look at relevance.
Again, this is a
blend of all cohorts,
because if you were just
looking at Millenials,
you'd probably see Red Bull
be completely off the page.
But what's interesting
about Red Bull
is the most interesting driver.
Certainly if you look at
some of the ways they engage
their target audience,
they do really
fun, colorful, extreme events.
People very clearly
associate them
with being one of most
interesting compound companies.
And Coca Cola, if
you're thinking
about an industry which
is flavored water-- right?
I mean, with all of the
secret formula, of course.
Coca Cola has done a good
job, a very good job,
across decades of maintaining
its brand leadership.
So you can start digging into
and using all those metrics
that I showed you a few
screens ago-- men and women,
ethnicities,
income-- and you can
start asking lots of questions.
I mean, talk about a
sensory experience.
Probably drinking
a beverage is one
of the most sensory
experiences you'll have.
And you saw the data that showed
that category loyalty to food
and beverages are
extremely high.
It's number one among
all respondents.
People stay loyal to Coke.
You can look at nonprofits.
I love this story about the
American Cancer Society,
because if you think of
all of the nonprofits,
they're dealing with a
pretty tough subject.
They're dealing with cancer.
So how do you make the
number one killer of people
in their mid middle years
or even younger years,
how do you engage people, other
than out of fear or sadness,
because they've been
a survivor or they
have a family member
that's experienced cancer?
Well, they've done a
particularly great job
about getting people into
the business of celebrating
birthdays, and getting people to
fight cancer by donating funds
or by walking a relay
race or doing something
positive to celebrate someone's
birthday that they love--
whether they're here as
themselves, someone who's
no longer here, or
it's a family member.
So it's taking a very,
very tough subject
and making it very
relevant to people
to do something about
in a positive way.
So they do a great job at that.
So this is some of
the new research
that I wanted to show you.
We asked people-- this is
probably two weeks old--
why people, why they're
loyal to brands, charities,
and political causes?
So again, we went back to
the questions about values.
Does the cause
stand for something
that's important to me?
Is it social?
Does it make me feel
good to support it?
Is it functional?
Does it meet needs?
And sensory-- it's
not for everyone,
but it's special for me.
There's something about
my emotional makeup
that makes me connect to it.
And it inspires me.
So the data, the new
data, shows that when
a product or service--
and you think
about that data I
showed you earlier,
which were high end products
or lower end products,
personal products--
function was very important
in that first
classification of data.
But now the sensory and emotive
piece starts to take over.
So people are starting to
say for the first time,
it makes me feel
good to support it.
So if you're an engineer and
you're developing a consumer
product, it's really
interesting to think
not only on the functional
aspects of that product,
but wow.
Can you imagine the person
that you're designing it
for is actually going to say,
I connect to that personally.
I feel really good
about supporting it.
And using it inspires me.
The next is the data that
came out about charities.
And I preempted myself
by saying definitely it's
all about my personal values.
But there has to be a
functional side to it.
And you see this with a lot
of community foundations,
foundations all over the world.
I mean, they're helping
a lot of people.
But people are starting to
look at new kind of generations
of foundations.
How are we actually creating
sustainable practices
with the people that
we were giving to
so that great work keeps
propagating itself?
Really interesting, this
sort of explains to me
the state of
affairs on politics.
But people, what's really
important to people
is when they vote for a
candidate is they like them.
When it gets down to the
functional side, when
you start talking about,
what's their track record?
You really start looking
into their backgrounds,
you'd think a lot of
people would really
concentrate on the
functional aspects.
The data is showing people
look at candidates and say,
I like them.
I like the way
they-- I mean, they
seem to stand for
the same things I do.
I associate it with values
that are important to me.
It's very, very
values, ethics driven.
And you can see why the
divides exist amongst parties,
because there are so many
different slices of values
and ethics in our nation.
So if you take a look
at collapsing the three
elements on this slide, you can
see that different sectors have
different balances,
different quadrant balances,
of relevance.
But there's such an opportunity.
And their balanced
for a good reason.
So my argument is,
I'm not suggesting
make all quadrants equal.
I'm not suggesting don't
lead where your strength is.
But what I'm
suggesting, there are
insights that you can find from
the other three quadrants that
can add a tremendous
emotional dimension
to the creative product that
you're putting out there
for people.
And I think we're
beginning to see
that the analytics and the
data do support creating
an insight that is
tremendously unique
and that's derived from a
very holistic look at a person
rather than just a
functional look at a person.
So here's some fresh new data.
It's a law firm.
You're thinking
about a law firm.
You're in the room
with your parents.
You both are thinking,
well, the firm I choose
will be the one with the
most successful track
record with the
greatest clients,
the greatest number
of cases won.
Is it a firm that I know?
Is it one I can
personally trust?
The firm, is it a social?
So for example, does it
have a really good track
record with social causes?
Is it recommended by a friend
or a family member or someone
in my business?
Or is finding a relationship
inside a firm with someone
that's really
committed to helping
me have a successful
outcome, that emotion?
Sort of falls more in
the sensory bucket.
And it's really interesting to
say that the whole red quadrant
lower right is the
firm I choose will
be the one I can
personally trust.
37% that was important to.
27% was the firm that was--
and this is collectively--
was the firm that helped
the individual achieve
a successful outcome.
The firm I choose will
be the one recommended
by another person, and then
finally the track record.
But it's interesting,
the youngest people
in our survey cared about
the track record the most.
And the older people, especially
in the 55 to 64-year-old range,
really care about the
commitment to the outcome.
So the lesson for us as
branders and marketers
is relevance changes.
Relevance changes.
It's circumstantial.
It changes with
how your life goes.
And it changes with
different situations.
It's very situational.
But the things-- and you'll
see also in banking--
that there's a trend to, in
the early parts of our lives,
we're thinking about maximizing
returns all the time.
Our data started to show
that people would actually
forego $1 of profit for a
long-standing relationship
with a financial
institution that
cared about you
across your lifetime.
So again, we asked them the
same sorts of questions.
I just gave you a
sneak peek into this.
The two leading
quadrants were one
about firms I know are used
by people I trust and respect.
So word of mouth,
very, very important
in financial services.
And the second one
was saving money.
The digital ease of use
was the smallest slice,
but most important, you'll
see, to the youngest audience.
And then this, the red part,
became very, very important
to people as they age.
So you can see how the
data kind of-- this chart
explains what I just said.
So I don't know if any
of you in this room
are still paying
off college loans.
I know I'm a parent.
I have three boys in college.
I was really fascinated with
the results of this survey.
So if you're thinking
about choosing a college--
and we looked, again, same
age spectrum-- what do you
care about?
Do you care about a
learning experience
that can help you
prepare for a career?
Do you care about a
learning experience
that socially connects
you to other people?
Is it your network you
get when you graduate?
Is it about an experience that
changes or shapes your values?
Or is it about
just something that
creates an overall
positive experience?
Well, unequivocally,
getting a job,
having an experience that
leads to a successful outcome
where you are employed
is incredibly important.
It's incredibly
important to people
who are in college,
who have recently
graduated from college,
or who are currently
paying for their
kids' college, or who
are paying off their loans.
So again, looking
at 10 years ago,
I think this would have
been very, very different.
I think the social networks,
if we'd have done this,
would have been very, very
important-- who you know,
who you meet.
Those are the tickets to
getting you a job later in life.
So again, this is the breakdown.
This shows how a college
university or learning
experience can prepare
you for a career.
Clearly, the leading indicator
across all age cohorts.
Very interesting.
So I've told you,
this is survey work.
So this is a lot of
marketing survey work.
There are also
pieces of relevance
that you can get which I just
call that are circumstantially.
And we look across one
of the tools we have,
it's a software product
that recognizing
keywords or phrases.
So we can look across
the social platforms.
And for example,
if we're looking
for a luxury good
hotel, we can see
how people, words,
or phrases that
are used in conversation or
dialogue that are associated
with Hilton, that are associated
with the Four Seasons, that
might be associated
with the Ritz Carlton.
And I use this example
because it's, we found,
a very, very
interesting insight.
We were looking at
luxury categories.
We had done our qualitative
and quantitative research.
We'd done all the
relevance profiles.
We saw this comment that
just kept cropping up
about Ritz Carlton hotels.
And the online dialogue,
the words and phrases
were all talking about the
water temperature and pressure
of Ritz Carlton hotels.
And they said, if you
are a business traveler,
you have got to stay
at a Ritz Carlton.
There's no better shower in
the world if you're traveling.
It's the temperature,
it's the pressure.
It's better than the coffee
or the great-smelling lobby,
or the soft towels,
or whatever it is.
It's the water
temperature and pressure.
You would have never
thought of that
when you were doing your
IDIs and interviewing people
about why they
choose hotel brands.
And that's an insight
that's very situational
that comes up out of nowhere.
And you have to allow for
that in your branding process.
You have to allow for stuff that
isn't structured to come up,
because some of the
greatest bits of creativity
come from that.
So how this all works is you
go through a methodology that
tries to get at the
very unique insights,
slicing and dicing it every
way, I showed you the data.
Once you have a couple of
insights you want to test,
you can use this M3
methodology that we've
developed with our partner,
which just allows you--
it's an algorithm-- and
it allows you to choose
your favorite choice and
your least favorite choice.
So you'd get 16
screens of a choice.
This most reflects
my preference,
this least reflects.
And what it allows you to
do is find the precise mix
of messages that support
your insight that
get you the maximum reach.
So for example, I would
be able to figure out,
once I knew something
more about you,
what four combinations
of messages
I might need to
communicate to you
to sell you a new bike, for
example, or a new camera.
Those, you can get very,
very specific with it.
And it takes some of
the risk out of it.
And you can see here, this is
an example of just the sample
size, how it changes when
you test the messages.
The other lesson
is, people think
it's really easy for people
that are driving brands,
or they make products,
to assume that they think
they know what the messages
are, and you learn so much
about testing with
just asking people.
Because sometimes the things you
assume are going to be correct
aren't.
So I mean, at the
end of the day,
this is sort of, towards
the end of things,
we've done this with a bunch of
clients over the last 25 years
from financial
services companies
to medical device companies
that are introducing power
sutures to pharmaceutical
companies to nonprofits.
And relevance, if
I could tell you
seven things that are
really important--
and this can be true for
building personal relevance,
like in your job or your
team-- is the best brands
are movements, not products.
They're the things that
you spark an insight that
gets people to capture it, and
then they carry it forward.
Those are the best brands.
They're not depending on
you putting that content
out there all the time.
People create the
content for themselves.
They help people
tell their stories.
And there are people--
everybody has different stories,
but there are
people that respond,
there are communities of
people that love and respond
to stories in different ways.
Relevance achieves that-- making
people feel better, not worse.
Having meaning in
this world, even
if you're talking
about cancer, you
have to give people something
that touches their compassion,
their ability to care
for friends and family.
They don't want to feel
worse then they already do.
They want to make new
connections, expand.
There's something
expansive about it.
It's easy and it's fun to
self-identify with a brand.
You feel like that brand
is connecting to you.
I mean, I think Chobani does
a really great job of that.
For a pretty broad-based
consumer brand,
Chobani does an awesome
job about speaking
to people where they are.
They know who they're trying to
reach, and they do a good job.
And ultimately,
you're meeting a need
and you're solving a problem.
I've told you about the work
that the American Cancer
Society does.
That's a great
example of relevance.
The second one I
would just talk to you
is a little bit the
Ocean Conservancy.
Here's an example
of how relevance
can make a difference.
They were struggling
with their donations.
They wanted to get their capital
campaign or their annual gift
giving campaign-- it wasn't
where they wanted it to be.
And their messaging was great,
their website was great.
But it wasn't doing the job.
What they found
through the research
was that instead of talking
to people about the ocean's
health-- like you should
care about the Atlantic Ocean
because the beaches are cleaner
and it's better fishing,
and there's no trash,
and marine life survives.
When people started
connecting the ocean's health
to their personal health,
that was the a-ha.
It's like, if that estuary
gets sick, you get sick.
If the water doesn't
work on our planet,
that's an enormous problem.
And if you use the right
combination of messages, A,
to get people to
care, to inspire them,
to connect with them, that
makes a huge difference.
So that turned out
to be the message,
connecting the ocean's health
with personal health, that
made the difference.
And the analytics and the
data behind the campaign
showed that.
So that's a fast
look run-through
of what relevance in the book.
And the book is a lot
more about stories
from my experience in business
and working with clients.
So thank you for giving me
the opportunity meet you
and share it.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
Nice to meet you.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: How do
you tackle fatigue?
So people, like these brands, if
everyone followed your advice,
then everyone is
going to find ways
to be more relevant
and more relevant,
and humans only have so much
attention that they can focus.
So is there a way
to handle customers
just getting fatigued of
being bombarded constantly
by these personalized messages?
ANDREA COVILLE: I agree.
And that's why I
started it the way
I did, because I think people
start self-selecting just
when they begin their day
about what they want to do.
So in this day and age, to
be able to connect with you--
which, from the starting
point, you have to be relevant.
That's the point.
First of all, you have
to know enough about you
or a brand that
would appeal to you
to get that to break through.
And it's going to get more
intense, not less intense.
And I think that's
the thing that brands
need to understand-- the
power of just creating
more and more information
for us at every-- I mean,
pretty soon I'm sure it will
be in every device we use,
there'll be some ability
to interact with content.
That content has to be relevant.
And the other point is, you
can't assume you are relevant.
I think the biggest
mistake companies
make are they assume they
have a great conversation
with their clients.
They assume they,
or their customers,
they know what they want.
And they don't.
And it's really hard to regain
relevance once you've lost it.
If you're making an
assumption that apps aren't
important in the
business environment
and you're developing products,
that's a tough, tough thing
to come back from.
So it's just
listening to people,
listening to lots
of people, looking
for unconventional
wisdom and insights.
Whoever came up with
the Zipcar idea,
what a great thing, if you think
about an unconventional wisdom
in a pretty conventional market.
Great example.
[APPLAUSE]